hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem neuen videos eingeblendet
die mit insgesamt 21 das ist so ein
anderer youtuber und ich meine man kennt
sich untereinander in der szene man weiß
so wer verliert sich selber habe
tausende kanäle deutschland abonniert
gucke allerdings gar keine videos weil
es einfach irgendwie schaffe jedenfalls
kam dann halt irgendwie sofort zwei
wochen so ein paar kommentare auf meinem
teller von wegen luca hat eigentlich ins
cockpit guck dir das mal an was der
gepostet habe ich hatte natürlich nicht
auf snapshot dann erstmal geendet
angeguckt hat irgendwas gesagt so von
wegen ja ich guck mir gerade das video
von crafter anwachsen das viel spaß
danke schön ist auch nicht schöner art
sich intern aber dann hat nichts weiter
dabei gedacht und das ganze helfer so
dabei beruhen lassen bis dann irgendwann
eine woche später also sollen video von
ihm dazu kamen erst mal freunde wenn ihr
in scope 21 nicht kennt hier einmal ein
kleiner ausschnitt aus seinen videos die
nachfolgende sendung ist nicht für
zuschauer ohne humor eignet hab dann
halt direkt abgeschaltet mehr sehen ist
mein ernst ist 21 ist ein lifestyle
youtuber ist wahrscheinlich 21 jahre alt
wieso bin ich so dumme denke dass er 21
in seinem namen drinsteht was bin ich
ein [ __ ] also ich habe mir dann
wirklich mal eine seiner letzten videos
angeschaut
da hat er sich dann so gegeben einer
meiner favorisierten fußballspieler
natürlich der sogenannte profispiele ok
erste reihe auf seinem kanal wo er
einfach sich videos von anderen youtube
anschaut und diese videos dann irgendwie
verarscht und darstellen die leute so
ein bisschen beleidigt das ganze ein
bisschen auf die schippe nehmen sich
dann ein letztes auf seinem kanal
gegangen bin habe ich dann gesehen ok
titel steht ein neuer gastes ampel wenig
hat er jetzt mit reiniger sie noch
meinen finger gebissen halter ich habe
das video angeklickt so ein bisschen
durch gekippt ist dann die stelle
krankenhäuser über mich geredet hat man
mir weiter mit dem nächsten youtuber ich
kann die noch nicht so lange noch sein
kanal wirklich frisch auf märkten
du kannst es wieder nicht man kann alex
die seit fünf jahren
danach hatte dann halt mal so ein
bisschen so meinen kanal bewertet sag
ich mal als aller erstes mal was ich mir
gut für dich sein profilbild sehr gut
ich mein letztes mal die als profilbild
du hast eine 21 ob das hier so großartig
kreativer ist weiß ich jetzt nicht aber
ich will jetzt gar nicht so oft zu
verbrechen schauen wir uns doch einfach
mal an das eda weiter von sich gegeben
hat ist aller erste video was ich mir
von ihm reingezogen hat es einen
wirklichen mega mega wieder im klick
eines video aber junge mann mein junge
freundin zum video mit dem titel room to
video aufnahme ist immer wie ein richtig
damit
viele geehrte ins loch 120 an dieser
stelle entschuldige ich mich dafür dass
sich bei dem video wo ich mein zimmer
gezeigt habe den titel ruhm tour gewählt
habe anstatt irgendwelche tippen erste
rote pfeile rote kreise drauf samt es
packen und das video irre führen zu
benennen
mit freundlichen grüßen com kräfte dann
hat er auch direkt herausgefunden dass
ich für ein typ bin
die fan von muskeln es ist jemand der
sich im putz mit seinen muskeln haut
muskeln dann redet er fordert er sich
dann auch noch ein aktuelleres video von
mir angeschaut hat ja jetzt habe ich mir
neues video von ihm angeschaut
auf der vds höher ist wirklich ein mega
mega kreatives video geworden an der
stelle wirklich noch mal ganz ganz ganz
viele grüße aus senden dankeschön eine
schöne grüße gehen auf jeden fall auch
zurück raus an dich und dann habe ich
gedacht okay gut dass wir zwei videos
von mir hoch genommen herzlichen glück
wurde fand ich jetzt sehr unterhaltsam
dein video der bringt das ganze sehen
wie zum ende sagt vielleicht dass seine
leute noch sein merge kaufen sollen und
das video leiden soll doch dann kam noch
diese aussage ich muss ich sagen ich
würde mich freuen wenn der kontrakt habe
ich einfach mal zurück diesen wird mit
dem soll ich mich echt gerne anliegen
und da dachte ich mir dann halt nur sein
ende sommer denkt wenn man mit dem be a
huge mit dem mit gleich gehts los
2000 jahre später im kopf du blöde kuh
wir jetzt mal richtig zu
du bist blöd das sage ich dir auf eine
blödheit trinke ich in mir
mal in ein fitnessstudio ich muss da
nicht hin denn ich bin schon so voll
cool und und muss da nicht hin weil ich
wünsche so voll cool und all die
probleme für java
du läufst ihr so nah war ich lieber
schnell nach porto ich habe das nur
gesagt damit sich rein dafür gebe ich
dir ein brot auf den kopf
ja umfang mit mikrochips mit mir will
man nicht [ __ ] weil keiner kann wie
ich ticken und auf dem bolzplatz kicken
und zudem biete nicken
ob du bist ja freunde das was ihr vom
video ich wollte das einfach mal nur
sagen weil mich viele darauf
angesprochen hat ich hab mir die halt
dieses neue komische keyboard linke
kaufen
ich meine dass ich schon cool alter wenn
euch das video gefallen dann würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen und spam
mal bei mir in die kompletten kommentare
und bei nico die ganzen kommentare in
skopje blödmann und vielleicht antwortet
er dann auf meinen track weil ich mir
damit so viel mühe gegeben und billig
spaß hier ist doch der knopf und die
kamera